j'écrivais sur la guerre il y a
longtemps j'écrivais un journal de
guerre
mérédith le dez écrit ce texte en 2014
et le lie à des artisans graveur saint
quentinois qui en débattent et en tire
une exposition ce texte en fait retrace
un peu le ressenti d'un soldat lors de
la de la grande guerre et donc partage
un peu ce désarroi qu'il ressent
notamment en période nocturne par
rapport à ce qui se passe et l'absurdité
de la guerre final ça a pris je dirais
quelques mois certaines sont peut-être
plus rapide que d'autres à réaliser le
travail de gravure il faut savoir que
c'est un travail qui est très lent qui
demande mûre réflexion qui demande aux
des tâtonnements des essais pour arriver
au résultat souhaité et en même temps
essayer de retranscrire des émotions
des émotions à lire dans une
cinquantaine de gravure à travers
différentes techniques monotype pointe
sèche aquatinte ou encore linogravure
une violence qu'on essaie de contenir
puisqu'on
forcément dans des sentiments qui
peuvent être désagréables
donc certains l'ont ressenti et le
retranscris tel qu'il ressentait
d'autres au contraire se sont un petit
peu je dirais pas pas caché mais on
était pudique dans l'eure dans le
ressenti on fait des choses peut-être
plus abstraites ou des choses je dirais
représentative mais beaucoup plus douce
des oeuvres qui se scrutent une à une
pour comprendre ne serait ce qu'un
instant le quotidien des poilus